we know one day I see that there are
people who speak French
so it's a good thing this
criticism is first of all why we
used these sports news where is my
friend dropped kenya who told me
you have a good atmosphere where jean
aucaigne hugo nveau you know i'm no
it's a board there I've already put
nets there he would have said cost of his
debt save sails to gino quilico
but called one coffin because yes  disappointed
because he is afraid of losing to colonel
koné decisive gives us doodle
innocents to the desire of players of my
age I have to reflect
the common card
[Music]
the excuses but mono but anything can
come and I love you boulgou game l  state of
peace in darfur de corts de limoges the
guy it takes a challenge 1919